[Music]
in silence is golden news sometimes
submitted by Clorox wipes great people
in this town could be fined for crying
or arguing in their own home in your
line is so much is this why do you cry
so much
bike first is it disturbing the silence
is this like a Dubai Thai place and like
a right but who's to say that that's
even happening do they put a camera in
your house you can hear from the window
like if you get a complaint like I was
calling in crying again but we see so
much teardrop limit yeah so this is
actually in Britain a British town
tonight really called
newcastle-under-lyme that's not a real
name do they say three words that's a
dream to [ __ ] order dude yeah
underline underline ly and I get the New
Castle the underlined one them green
citrus yes with the white ly and E so
they're saying that now there's this new
rule that is issued by local councils to
prevent residents from disrupting their
neighbors everyday life so they're
saying that Ryan is so cathartic
what if there's just that one [ __ ]
tenant that's insane and crying like
crazy all the time that bothers all of
them what about happy tears this is
introduced by Prime Minister Theresa May
when shocked when she was a secretary on
the British Cabinet in 2014 and they're
saying that this would be applied to
anyone above the age of 16 so they're
saying that good I guess because
children cry and like make noise that
think little but you're still a kid at
17 107 to a turn that's what you do the
most crying yeah did a resident
oh can I so not to create any wailing
jabbering crying
hammering on the wall type noises so if
these noises can be heard outside of any
property then that person will get fined
maybe a lot of people cry in this
apartment compliment the wall it just
sounds are slamming I mean they could be
separate things it kind of makes sense
coming from Brenda because they are a
country of my etiquette and certain like
behavior there's a lot of like manners
because that's more like the whole
gentleman's concept came from you know
what's funny about that oh I met some
fans who are flight attendants right and
they work for Emirates and in their
saying that [ __ ] British British
tourists are like wild like they're like
they're like finally be [ __ ] humans
they're like hella rude and like mean
and like different loose or something
yeah when I traveled in Europe and every
time it's not an American tourist it's a
British tourist that's like being a
sanely rowdy being kicked out well
they're the original colonizers dude
makes sense
[ __ ] they're like British and Chinese
tourists are the worst customers oh
really yeah and I was like oh I thought
it would be Americans and are like
America's just like they just have a
dress sloppy and like kind of like
different but not as bad as how they get
treated by British customers or Chinese
customers if the interaction part
sometimes I couldn't used this because
my the last place that I lived in my
condo neighbourhood their kids were so
[ __ ] loud and it was like demos you
know when we talk about we make fun of
that stereotype of that disrespectful
white kid dude they're [ __ ] daughters
were the most disrespectful shits I've
ever heard in my life
like you're a white of course and so hey
there's one time I could hear this [ __ ]
so khalif's wall is connected to the
kids room and then I'm upstairs as - not
connect I could still hear them yelling
but I'm talking about some [ __ ] like the
dad would say sweetie you need to put on
your jacket cuz it's cold out so he goes
you're not
I should like that
and just screaming and he's like no and
then mom would come in and then mom
would say sweetie you need to listen to
Daddy
exactly and in my mind I'm like yo
somebody [ __ ] this kid up dude but I
had a problem with the neighbor one time
because I was watching a movie in my
room and I guess it was a little too
loud for them and mind you their kids
were yelling at them every day and so it
was I was too loud for the missile he
started fighting [ __ ] and so the next
morning and this is like when I was
trying to be I was trying to learn how
to speak a little more polite but it
still came out wrong either way because
I talked to him the next day knocked on
this door I was like hey was I too loud
for you last night and he goes yeah we
were trying to sleep I was like but I
had the movie on and run like 9:30 or
something and quiet times around 10:00
so I was like did you also know that
your kids wake us up every morning when
you when they scream and I don't say
[ __ ] to you and you're not the boss of
them I don't say anything to you I said
when you bang on my wall like that it
sounds like you want to fight so do you
want to fight me he goes oh no that's
not what I meant I was like well that's
cool but when you bang on my wall it
makes you seem like you and I want to
get into an altercation so I don't talk
[ __ ] about your kids even though they're
being on the walls that you know why
it's because you're my neighbor I
understand it's hard to control kids so
I just want that same respect back
so but like it's kind of crazy how you
start banging on my [ __ ] wall but
there's all the kids yeah [ __ ] drive
him crazy
yeah he doesn't know what to do so he's
taking that anger out on the wall some
funnier [ __ ] - [ __ ] Khalifa's
hilarious because he saw there you know
the [ __ ] during Christmas the kids
wrote this letter to Santa I left it on
the medically grabbed it went
we've been really good kids Santa ho
basically thought he goes no the garbage
can you read it first I like that it's
funny because Jenna doesn't exist but
he's like just in case just in case any
going to sad edges [ __ ] believe me
he's picking on kids yeah it's [ __ ]
cool I guess that makes sense then cuz
it kind of warns you from like when
you're making a ton of noise it'll stop
because you're like I'm not gonna get
fined oh yeah like it'll it'll like that
dude would have tried harder to shut the
kids up for we know it would cost money
oh yeah
like yeah so the fines were saying that
they face if they fail to comply they
face and on the spot fine of a 100
British pounds or about $126 or a fine
up to two thousand five hundred pounds
which is about 3116 damn that's a lot
and businesses Wow
businesses can be fined up to 20
thousand pounds which is about twenty
five thousand three hundred eleven oh my
god we would have been fine so many
times have to be quiet the whole time
yeah yeah that's always not even like a
like a time thing it's like all day all
right it's just if you definitely knows
that your neighbor could hear outside
Wow damn or these apartments made out of
origami aren't these buildings I like
kind of old like in Britain don't they
kind of preserve the structures so you
can't really like add [ __ ] to your
colonial home whatever what's crazy too
is how do they prove it like let's say
we're neighbors yeah they don't like you
yeah and I'm just like hey he keeps
making noise he's interrupting and
you're just like no I didn't so it's my
word against yours like how did they
prove maybe you gotta like record it
yeah
at the cage own apartment those is crazy
guy to live beneath us too and he came
up knocked on a door so we just we need
to stop having dance parties it was
[ __ ] 10 a.m. in the morning I was
asleep
feels like you're having dance party he
was on drugs
he was so this was going some crazy [ __ ]
in his [ __ ] place cuz he always had
the lights off and he had like goggles
on his head all the [ __ ] time
[ __ ] freak disciples mining it is on
the fire yeah and he's very surly no
under our door cursing us out of [ __ ]
[ __ ] piss me off dance parties and
[ __ ] how did you get a lot of [ __ ] up
neighbors ma'am and Kate town and
[ __ ] Pasadena I don't remember what
it's like to have a [ __ ] up neighbor I
want to shake my fist at somebody you're
the [ __ ] that maybe maybe that's why you
don't know you're the dance party guy
yeah I know dude recently I felt bad but
it just it had to be done I complained
about my neighbors so good can you
become an adult but listen still let me
tell you whole situation so in the
apartment complex that we live there
like townhomes and the apartment at the
end of the building we're like 2nd to
the end right and so in our place we're
renting from the owners and the owners
are cousins with the people that owned
our neighbors and so what ended up
happening is for many like it had
happened like about five or six times
already that in the middle of the night
these people are hanging out outside on
the patio
what which is like you guys remember our
place like our bedroom we had like a
big-ass sliding glass door and that
glass doors on the second story but then
the first story of the neighbor that's
where the patio is oh yeah don't walk
I'll go straight up there exactly the
noise just go straight up there and it's
like dude our place is so soundproof
that if you just hang out inside we
won't hear anything but they just kept
hanging out outside and it's so hot we I
mean what they have a/c you like what
they're Chinese no they're not actually
don't know where they are um I think
they might be Italian we don't let go
use a AC yeah I like Italian American
like they're pretty much just white
people I guess you make a hot of pizza
but um so yeah so then many times we
went out and complain and they're like
oh I'm so sorry we're never gonna do it
again and we're like dude you went to
the house we went our Casey went over
and like I was cute we went no no
because it happened so many times but
case you did the first few times and
then at one point I just got so mad
because Casey was asleep and I was away
cuz I'm the one that sleeps closest to
that window so I'm like holy [ __ ] I
can't sleep
but then this last time it was 3 a.m.
damn that's too late yeah 3:00 a.m. guys
go out at the time they're out outside
like yo you guys are loud yeah so but at
this time when I was 3 a.m. I was so
exhausted and I and then I could hear
them like their laughter woke me up they
was having a good time yeah and that cuz
they're drinking outside too so I'm like
what the [ __ ] so somehow is a bit it was
able to go to sleep and then and then
they wake me up again when they come
inside because they're like they ended
up going out to the balcony which is
right next to the actual glass thing and
they woke me up again I'm like holy [ __ ]
it's almost 5:00 in the morning and
these [ __ ] won't go to sleep
were they young um so the thing is the
woman that owned that place
she died recently and her daughter took
over and so her daughter has this really
crazy boyfriend who apparently have they
have had this really long relationship
and he's just like a crazy dude that
always called me albums he's Italian
gangster he seems like he kind of he's
getting gangster I didn't know the mob
existed where we are at and then
gangster over here and then you want
Tommy Bahama's it's like that like long
sleeve stretch that all them off you
guys we're you know what you all had to
do you just gotta wait for them to get
really drunk roofie up their [ __ ]
drinks knocked in the [ __ ] out beat the
[ __ ] out of them leave them back in the
house and just say last warning like did
I fall down but they also have is yappy
ass dog and that dog woke me up I got
all woken up three times that night and
finally I called my landlord I'm like
listen we put up with this [ __ ] for
months and I didn't want to be a
tattletale and be that neighbor because
we have gone to them so many times can
you please make it stop last night I
couldn't sleep this is getting out of
hand so he finally talked and then
that's when he told me the tea about the
boyfriend he was like yeah my my niece
she's just been with this guy like he's
every time he's around they were always
because they have arguments all the time
to know Mike you just kill the [ __ ]
dog
that sends a warning be bothering you
crying you'll call the cops on them and
say like hey I'm so worried I must have
to spew somebody's getting raped yes
feels like listen I know you don't want
to do this but if it gets bad again
you're just gonna have to call the cops
and I'm like oh I would love to now do
you think other neighbors love it yeah
other neighbors she does seem like
pretty G like I would you other
neighbors so many guns they'll be
anonymous all the cops they'll come and
who it is though where the unit is
that's why you got to move to Santa
Clarita there's no one else complaining
going excuse me but you're lying there
in this building right there at the end
we're here like there's no one near them
but us oh you're the only one to talk to
the cop like after you're done talking
to them come over to our house being on
our door go you guys [ __ ] up - you guys
can relate to that it's like dude
somebody's been ratting us out Oh
perfect everyone needs a old white lady
that lives out there they regulate that
[ __ ] lady her name is Gloria she's
[ __ ] funny we have so many stories
like this she does she does she regulate
well so she lives at the building up
like this higher is this for an old lady
to like do that job oh why ladies though
you know the most the problem is they
know it's you I would want that person
to know it was me that what kind of
person are you gonna do [ __ ] dude he's
not gonna do [ __ ] [ __ ] oh now we have
balls David huh no this is what our
friends
I'm docile but that [ __ ] debri
go do [ __ ] [ __ ] you let them know
it's you so yeah it's me [ __ ]
[ __ ] do something [ __ ] they
live you know
now that they've had this long crazy
relationship heat that my landlord was
telling me that they would break up when
he went to jail who the [ __ ] we know a
lot of people that went to jail with the
[ __ ] farts being to jail you have
well no no for expired dog tag trying to
make your gangster
I did hear that one
[Music]
you
[Music]